les forces de l'ordre ont tiré mardi sur
des manifestants angor un quartier
populaire de Dakar des citoyens surtout
des jeunes manifestent depuis des
semaines contre la construction d'une
gendarmerie sur un terrain convoité
plutôt pour une école secondaire nous
sommes dans un pays dans mon corps
pratique où il y a la liberté
d'expression où il y a la liberté de
circuler
ce village en ce moment pendant des
jours les policiers ont bouclé le
quartier empêchant les résidents d'en
sortir ou d'y entrer quand la
manifestation a viré à l'émeutes les
blessés non plus être évacués rapidement
une jeune fille de 15 ans est décédée
sur la plage être touché par balle avant
d'être traîné dans un sac par les forces
de l'ordre ce que ni le gouvernement les
informations sur les meubles sont
parcellaires parce que les policiers ont
bloqué
[Musique]
les manifestations au Sénégal sont plus
souvent interdites donc réprimer et
dispersé par la force les journalistes
Sénégalais sont aussi de plus en plus
victimes d'intimidation de brutalité
policière quand des radios ne sont pas
carrément suspendues en fait en matière
de respect de la liberté de presse
commence à s'effriter petit à petit
toutes les tentatives de musulmans aussi
bien de la presse de la population où
tout opinion divergente et
systématiquement condamnés ce qui pose
même un problème d'un état de droit au
Sénégal on se dit est-ce qu'on est
toujours en tout cas dans un état de
droit ce n'est plus de la justice et du
banditisme judiciaire
Ousmane Sonko
disqualifié comme candidat aux élections
il accuse le gouvernement d'utiliser les
tribunaux pour éliminer des opposes dans
l'histoire politique du Sénégal on n'a
jamais vu on n'a jamais assisté à une
situation pareille jamais on a assisté à
un tel acharnement contre candidat
les opposants protestent aussi contre
l'intention présumée du président Macky
Sall de solliciter un troisième mandat
ce qui est interdit par la Constitution
sénégalaise et plus le président laisse
planer la possibilité d'un troisième
mandat plus la tension monte les parties
d'opposition prévoit une vaste
manifestation vendredi
il y en aura combien jusqu'où les gens
vont s'arrêter et accepter de discuter
car s'il est justice bloque la
candidature d'Ousmane Sonko ses
partisans risque d'imposer leur voix
dans la rue ici Sophie Langlois
Radio-Canada Montréal